It was one of those jobs that could either fill you with a sense of despair, or make you feel like you love the world and fill you with a sense of mission every day. Michael Beaumier chose the second path.
这工作有时会让你感到绝望，有时却让你每天都觉得热爱世界，充满使命感。迈克尔·博米尔选择了后者。
I always ask people, are you married? Are you dating? Is it serious? What are you looking for?
我总是问别人，你结婚了吗？你在约会吗？是认真的吗？你在寻找什么样的伴侣？
Michael Beaumier runs the personals ads for a weekly paper, the Chicago Reader. And he takes it so to heart that he is constantly talking to people who place the ads. He not only tells them how to fix their ads so they can find the kind of person they might want, he remembers them. If he talks to somebody else who might like them, he tells that person to look up their ad.
迈克尔·博米尔负责《芝加哥读者》周报的征友广告板块。他把这件事看得非常重，经常与刊登广告的人交流。他不仅告诉他们如何修改广告以找到心仪的对象，还会记住他们。如果他觉得某人适合另一位客户，就会建议那个人去看看对方的广告。
If somebody called me and said, is there an ad that I should answer this week? And they told me a little bit about what they're looking for. I think that off the top of my head I could say, yeah, here are three people that you should respond to.
如果有人打电话问我，这周有没有值得联系的广告？并告诉我他们想找什么样的人。我想我脱口就能说出：有，这三个人你应该联系一下。
How many of the people in the personals do you know personally, have you talked to yourself?
你亲自认识、亲自交谈过征友板块里的多少人？
Well, I try really hard to not be involved.
嗯，我尽量不去介入。
Dozens.
几十个。
Dozens, yeah. And I keep lots of notes in my office too, in terms of, well, here's this woman. And she's looking for a date. So I'll give her a call and go, hey, you know, here is this guy. He's in this week. You should call him. I'm not supposed to do that. But I do it anyhow because I just can't help myself.
几十个，没错。我的办公室里也留了很多笔记，比如，这位女士，她在找对象。我会打电话给她说，嘿，你知道吗，这周来了位男士，你应该给他打个电话。虽然我不该这么做，但我还是忍不住做了，因为我就是管不住自己。
In a way, it's hard to believe that the perfect person ended up in that job. A few years back, Michael noticed in the missed connections section of the personals-- you know that section where people say, I saw you on the Clark Street bus. Our eyes locked. Call me. There was this guy who was taking out one missed connections ad after another. Five of them, 10 of them, 15 of them.
从某种程度上讲，很难相信那个职位上竟然坐着这么完美的人选。几年前，迈克尔注意到征友板块里的“错失缘分”栏目——你知道那个栏目，人们会在上面写：我在克拉克街的公交车上看见你。我们目光交汇。请给我打电话。当时有个家伙接连刊登了好多条“错失缘分”广告。五条、十条、十五条。
He had people that he would see on the train. You were the Asian woman in the purple dress. You were reading Ayn Rand. Or I saw you at Gamekeepers. You were the brown-haired girl. Your hair was in a pony tail. You were wearing an Ohio State sweatshirt.
他会在火车上看到不同的人。你是那个穿紫色连衣裙的亚裔女性。你在读安·兰德的书。或者，我在酒吧见过你。你是那个棕色头发的女孩。你扎着马尾辫。你穿着俄亥俄州立大学的运动衫。
15 ads like this.
15条这样的广告。
15 ads. He would see women all over town, Wicker Park, Bucktown, the trains out to O'Hare, at O'Hare, on flights back from places to come back to Chicago. And it was just getting crazy. And he really, really meant them. They were very, very earnest ads.
15条。他会在城里各处看到女性，威克公园、巴克镇、去奥黑尔机场的火车上，在奥黑尔机场，或是从外地飞回芝加哥的航班上。这简直快要疯了。而且他是真心的，这些广告都非常、非常诚恳。
He would come in sometimes. Usually he would email ads to me or he would give them to me over the phone. I would talk to him over the phone at least twice a week.
他有时会亲自过来。通常他会用电子邮件把广告发给我，或者通过电话告诉我。我每周至少和他通两次电话。
Did you ever see him?
你见过他吗？
Oh, yeah. I saw him a couple of times.
哦，见过的。我见过他几次。
Cute?
长得帅吗？
Oh, yeah. Yes, very cute. But just really, really quiet. And I think some people find quiet to be creepy. But he was quiet kind of like he didn't want to impose on anybody by having conversation with them, that he felt that he wasn't an interesting person. And I think that he was a very interesting person.
哦，是的，非常帅。但真的很安静。我觉得有些人会觉得这种安静令人毛骨悚然。但他那种安静好像是因为不想通过交谈去打扰别人，他觉得自己不是个有趣的人。但我认为他其实是一个非常有趣的人。
Michael would give him these little pep talks, encourage him to start speaking to these women instead of just seeing them and then taking out an ad. And weeks passed of this. And months passed. And finally, Michael just got tired. And he wrote him this letter. He told him to make 20 copies and carry them with him wherever he goes.
迈克尔会给他一些小鼓励，劝他主动去和那些女性说话，而不是只看着她们然后刊登广告。日子一天天、一个月月地过去了。最终，迈克尔厌倦了。他写了这封信给他。他让他复印20份，随身携带。
This is what I wrote. It reads, "To whom it may concern. My name is Mike Beaumier. I run the personal ad department at the Reader, the matches. The gentleman who handed you this note is named Bill. I've come to know Bill very well. In many ways, he reminds me of my father, quiet, decent, dedicated, someone who probably falls under the radar for most people. He neither drinks nor smokes. He is close to his parents and siblings. He has a job, a home, a car, and some place to be in the morning, and many friends who, like me, think highly of him. Once you get to know the guy, you'll wonder why nobody snapped him up yet. I often do, and romance is my business.
这是我写的内容。上面写着：“致相关人士。我叫迈克·博米尔。我负责《芝加哥读者》的征友匹配部门。递给你这张字条的绅士名叫比尔。我很了解比尔。在很多方面，他让我想起我的父亲，安静、正派、专注，是个容易被大多数人忽略的人。他不喝酒也不抽烟。他和父母、兄弟姐妹关系亲密。他有工作、有家、有车，每天早上有地方去，还有许多像我一样对他评价很高朋友。一旦你了解了他，你就会纳闷为什么还没人把他抢走。我常这么想，而恋爱正是我的业务。”
Anyway, here is why I'm writing this letter. Bill is very shy. I'm not sure why. He's very smart and really funny. I'm asking you, someone I do not know, to please, please, please save us all a lot of trouble and let this man buy you a cup of coffee. Because if you don't, Bill is just going to put in another missed connections ad in my paper. And I will once more have to give him another lecture about having the courage to approach interesting women. If Bill doesn't give you his home phone number, I will. Please feel free to call me at my office number below. Sincerely, Mike Beaumier, matches coordinator, Chicago Reader.
“总之，我写这封信的原因是：比尔非常害羞。我不确定为什么。他很聪明，而且非常风趣。我请求你，一位我不认识的人，请、请、请帮我们一个大忙，让这个男人请你喝杯咖啡。因为如果你不这么做，比尔就又要在我报纸上刊登另一条‘错失缘分’广告了。而我又得再给他上一课，教他如何鼓起勇气去结识有趣的女性。如果比尔没给你他的家庭电话，我会给的。请随时拨打我下方的办公室号码联系我。诚挚地，迈克·博米尔，《芝加哥读者》匹配协调员。”
And I think that he used it, because I had maybe one more ad from him after this. And then it stopped.
我想他用了这封信，因为在那之后，我只收到过他的一条广告。然后就没下文了。
OK. By any standards, that is above and beyond the call of duty. And there are so many people out there like this, little guardian angels in all sorts of walks of life, trying to save the world one person at a time. Today on our radio program, stories of people like that. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
好的。无论用什么标准衡量，这都已经超出了职责范围。世界上有很多人像这样，在各行各业扮演着守护天使的角色，试图一个接一个地拯救世界。今天在我们的电台节目里，我们要讲述的就是这类人的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是由公共广播国际发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
In collecting the stories for today's radio show, it became clear to all of us who work on the program that not only did most of these stories have to do with people saving the world, in every story people have these sudden moments of truth delivered to them by complete strangers.
在搜集今天节目的故事时，我们所有制作组人员都很清楚，这些故事不仅是关于拯救世界，在每个故事里，人们都是从陌生人那里突然得到了真理的时刻。
Act One of our show today, The Rundown. In that act, the story of one girl's mission to bring people together everywhere by eliminating small talk forever. It can happen in our lifetimes, friends.
我们今天节目的第一幕，“简要报告”。在这一幕里，讲述了一个女孩的使命：通过彻底消除闲聊，让人们随时随地聚在一起。朋友们，这在我们有生之年是有可能实现的。
Act Two, Heather Help Me. The story of some teenagers, a telephone, and a man who only answers to a name that is not his.
第二幕，“希瑟救救我”。关于一些青少年、一部电话，以及一个只用非自己名字回应的男人的故事。
Act Three, Fools Rush in Where Mommies Fear to Tread. In that act, an art history professor tries to talk with his fists.
第三幕，“傻子闯入妈咪避让之地”。在这一幕中，一位艺术史教授试图用拳头进行交流。
Act Four, The Science of Good and Bad. The story of a simple test, just two lists of 18 items each, designed to tell you who you are, increase good, identify evil, one person at a time. When our reporter takes the test herself, the results spook her for weeks. Stay with us.
第四幕，“善恶的科学”。关于一个简单测试的故事，仅由两份各18项的清单组成，旨在告诉你你是谁，增加善意，识别邪恶，一次一个人。当我们的记者亲自进行测试时，结果让她连续几周感到惊恐。敬请收听。
Act One, The Rundown. Well, one of the producers of our radio show, Starlee Kine, in addition to her many duties here at the public radio station, has been going around giving a lecture, proselytizing on behalf of something that she invented that she calls The Rundown. Her idea is this. Very, very simple. Small talk is not bringing us together. Small talk is the enemy. Small talk must end. And she proposes replacing small talk with The Rundown.
第一幕，“简要报告”。嗯，我们节目的制作人之一斯塔莉·凯恩，除了在公共广播电台的许多职责外，一直在四处演讲，宣传她发明的一种叫做“简要报告”的东西。她的想法非常、非常简单。闲聊并不能让我们聚在一起。闲聊是敌人。闲聊必须结束。她提议用“简要报告”来代替闲聊。
A warning to more sensitive listeners. She refers to the idea of virgins and sex in this brief lecture. This was recorded at one of her public lectures.
提醒一下较为敏感的听众。她在这次简短的演讲中提到了处女和性的概念。这是在她的一次公开讲座中录制的。
I know a lot about small talk, because I worked in an office. And there is a lot of small talk that goes on. There are like all these different forms of it. There is like water cooler small talk. And there's elevator small talk, which actually isn't even that bad, because most people think elevator small talk is the worse kind. But actually, I think it's OK, because it is finite. You know it's going to end at a certain point, which I appreciate very much. There's even bathroom small talk where I work, which is like the worst thing you're ever going to experience in your entire life. There will be people small talking through the stalls.
我对闲聊了解很多，因为我在办公室工作过。有很多闲聊在发生。它们有各种各样的形式。有饮水机旁的闲聊。还有电梯里的闲聊，其实还不算太糟，因为大多数人认为电梯闲聊是最糟糕的一种。但其实我觉得还行，因为它是有限的。你知道它在某个点就会结束，我很欣赏这一点。甚至还有洗手间的闲聊，在我工作的地方，这简直是你一生中经历过最糟糕的事情。会有隔着隔间闲聊的人。
I actually have some audio of small talk to play for you.
我其实有一些闲聊的录音可以放给你们听。
Coffee is on its way. Here is a special selection of the Viking blend. And I have to get back to work.
咖啡快好了。这是维京混合咖啡的特别精选。我得回去工作了。
That's what happened in my office. Almost every day that seems to happen, actually. We know we are drinking coffee. It's being made. But for some reason, when you do small talk-- when you're caught in the trap of small talk-- you feel you just have to talk about what's immediately happening in front of you, even though it's so obvious.
这就是我办公室发生的事情。事实上，几乎每天似乎都会发生。我们都知道我们在喝咖啡。咖啡正在煮。但出于某种原因，当你陷入闲聊——当你被困在闲聊的陷阱里——你觉得你必须谈论眼前立刻发生的事情，即使它是如此显而易见。
And it's not even his fault. You know what I mean? Everyone does it. And so I can't take it anymore. So I devised The Rundown to eliminate small talk forever from the world. I want it to be done with. The Rundown, the goal of The Rundown is it's supposed to turn conversations from the conversations you're supposed to be having to the conversations you want to be having.
甚至都不是他的错。你知道我的意思吗？每个人都这样。所以我再也受不了了。所以我设计了“简要报告”来永远消除世界上的闲聊。我希望它能终结。简要报告，简要报告的目标是把你们“应该”进行的对话变成你们“想要”进行的对话。
And so I also have an example of The Rundown. I went to a movie. And there's a ticket guy selling tickets. And I just started talking to him. So it can be done on anyone.
所以我也有一个“简要报告”的例子。我去看了场电影。有个售票员在卖票。我直接开始跟他聊天。所以它可以对任何人进行。
I had ramen noodles for breakfast.
我早餐吃了拉面。
The $.25 ones or the fancy ones?
25美分那种还是高级的那种？
I didn't pay for them. My girlfriend bought them.
我没花钱买。是我女朋友买的。
OK. So if you're thinking small talk, you're going to go after the ramen noodles, right? Like what kind of ramen noodles, hot water, meat, something like that. But if you're doing The Rundown, you just seize on the most interesting part of the conversation. And so he did give me a very, very valuable clue. He gave me this wonderful girlfriend character to work with. From that, you can proceed to--
好的。所以如果你在进行闲聊，你肯定会追问拉面的事，对吧？比如什么拉面、热水、肉之类的。但如果你在做“简要报告”，你就抓住对话中最有趣的部分。他确实给了我一个非常有价值的线索。他给了我这个很棒的女朋友角色可以深挖。从那开始，你可以继续——
Are you in love?
你坠入爱河了吗？
I love her.
我爱她。
But you don't know if-- you're not in love?
但你不知道是否——你不是在热恋中吗？
Oh, well, I think yeah. I am definitely in love.
哦，嗯，我想是的。我绝对坠入爱河了。
OK. So that's a little bit more to go with. Now we know he's capable of love, which is a lot more than knowing that he just had ramen noodles. And from there the possibilities just open up wide. You can pretty much go for anything now. So then you just keep going.
好的。所以这就多了一些内容可以挖掘。现在我们知道他有爱的能力，这比仅仅知道他吃了拉面要多得多。从那里，可能性就完全打开了。你现在几乎可以聊任何事了。所以你就继续聊下去。
So how many one night stands have you had?
那你有过多少次一夜情？
Well, I know how many girls I've been with. But I never really counted which of them were one night stands exactly.
嗯，我知道我和多少女孩在一起过。但我从没算过她们之中确切有多少是一夜情。
How many girls?
多少个女孩？
34 and 1/2.
34个半。
34 and 1/2. How many virgins?
34个半。有多少个处女？
Estimate? Roughly, probably four or five.
估算一下？大概，可能是四个或五个。
So you might think how many virgins is an inappropriate question. But I actually think it's like the perfect fallback if you have nothing else to ask. You know I mean? Because as you can see, it's totally OK. He doesn't mind telling you. People are just wait-- they love to talk about themselves. And that's what people want. And they also like to be asked questions that they have answers for. He completely knows the answer to how many virgins.
所以你可能会想，问有多少处女是一个不恰当的问题。但我其实认为，如果你没别的问题可问，这简直是完美的退路。你懂我的意思吗？因为正如你所见，这完全没问题。他不介意告诉你。人们只是等待——他们热爱谈论自己。这就是人们想要的。而且他们也喜欢被问到他们有答案的问题。他完全知道处女数量的答案。
So then they feel good about themselves. And they'll keep going. And from there it is pretty smooth sailing.
所以他们感觉良好。然后他们会继续说下去。从那里开始就是一帆风顺了。
The first one that came along was for two and a half years. That was the first girl I was ever with though.
第一个来到我身边的是在一起两年半。那是我的第一个女朋友。
That was?
是吗？
She was a virgin too. We were both virgins. It was good. But it was weird. It was kind of like an all day all around town sort of thing, because it started at her grandparents' house, which was in this all yellow room. The sheets were yellow, the window curtains were yellow. And it just wasn't working out. It was kind of-- So then we drove out to this spot by a drive in movie screen that was abandoned. But it was a good experience altogether. I enjoyed it.
她也是个处女。我们都是处女。这感觉很好。但很奇怪。就像是一种整天整晚在城里转悠的感觉，因为这开始于她祖父母的家，那是一个全是黄色的房间。床单是黄色的，窗帘是黄色的。事情进展得不顺利。有点……所以我们就开车去了那个废弃的汽车电影院旁边。但总的来说，这是一次不错的经历。我很享受。
So that was a minute and 26 seconds. And now, after a minute and 26 through The Rundown, I know what he's had for breakfast, that he is capable of love, how many girls he has slept with, how many of them are virgins, who he first lost his virginity to, and even the color wallpaper of her grandmother's house. So that's pretty good. That's a pretty successful Rundown.
所以那是1分26秒。现在，通过“简要报告”进行了1分26秒后，我知道了他早餐吃了什么，他有爱的能力，他和多少女孩睡过，其中有多少是处女，他第一次把童贞献给了谁，甚至她祖母家墙纸的颜色。所以那很不错。那是一个相当成功的“简要报告”。
And there are a few simple rules for everyone to be able to do it just like this, eventually. So the first rule is, number one, small talk is the conversation you're supposed to be having. And The Rundown is the conversation you want to be having. Number two is, why chew the fat, when you can chew the meat? Also very important. Number three is, if you can think it, you can ask it. And then, if all else fails-- or even if all else doesn't fail-- number four is, how many virgins? So, that's The Rundown.
并且有一些简单的规则，让每个人最终都能像这样做到。所以第一条规则是，第一，闲聊是你应该进行的对话，而“简要报告”是你想要进行的对话。第二条规则是，当你可以吃肉的时候，为什么还要咀嚼脂肪呢？这点也很重要。第三，如果你能想到，你就能问出来。然后，如果一切都失败了——或者即使一切都没有失败——第四条规则是：有多少处女？这就是“简要报告”。
Starlee Kine, speaking at The Little Gray Book Lectures at the Galapagos Art Space in New York.
斯塔莉·凯恩，在纽约加拉帕戈斯艺术空间的“小灰书讲座”上的发言。
Well, this brings us to Act Two, an act we're calling Heather Help Us. It is this story of people reaching out and giving the rundown of their lives to a complete stranger. Jessica Riddle tells the tale.
好吧，这把我们带到了第二幕，我们称之为“希瑟救救我们”。这是一个人们向陌生人伸出援手并提供他们生活“简要报告”的故事。杰西卡·里德尔讲述了这个故事。
Recently, I remembered this thing that happened back when I was in high school. And it was so incredible that I sort of wondered whether it really happened. What it was was when I was around 15, my friends and I used to call this number. It was our area code plus the name Heather, H-E-A-T-H-E-R. An old man would answer the phone and talk to you about anything. It was kind of creepy, I remember.
最近，我记起了高中时发生的一件事。它是如此不可思议，以至于我有点怀疑它是否真的发生过。大概是我15岁的时候，我和朋友们常拨打一个号码。那是我们地区的区号加上“希瑟”的名字，H-E-A-T-H-E-R。一位老人会接听电话并和你聊任何事情。我记得那有点诡异。
So I checked around. It turns out my friend Kirsten had the same memory too.
所以我查了一下。原来我的朋友克里斯汀也有同样的记忆。
Well, it started out as sort of an urban legend. We'd be at parties or something, and they would just be like, yeah, you know when you dial Heather, H-E-A-T-H-E-R. And you can talk to him about anything. And I think at parties or something people would call him and be like, so, how many little boys have you got locked in your basement? And they would just mess with him.
好吧，它最初有点像都市传说。我们在聚会或其他场合时，他们就会说，嘿，你知道拨打“希瑟”，H-E-A-T-H-E-R吗。你可以和他聊任何事情。我想在聚会时人们会给他打电话说，那么，你地下室锁了多少个小男孩？他们只是拿他寻开心。
I remember sort of sicking Heather on people, like them being like, you know, I wish that so and so would just get off my back. And I'd be like, call Heather. You know? Just call Heather.
我记得曾拿希瑟去压制别人，比如他们说，哎，我希望某某人能别再缠着我了。我会说，打给希瑟吧。你知道吗？直接打给希瑟。
Well there was a fair amount of passing the phone around, just to get your words in or just hear what he had to say. But I think it was more like sleepovers and things. It was more like crank calling him at first.
好吧，大家确实经常传递电话，只是为了说上几句，或者听听他要说什么。但我认为更像是过夜派对之类的时候。起初更像是恶作剧电话。
But over time, it seemed like the prank conversations evolved into more regular conversations. I remember friends of mine calling and asking questions like, hey, Heather, what's 44 down? Heather, what do you think? Should I join the lacrosse team? Heather, what do you think of the color green? But I didn't realize how serious the conversations were until Kirsten told me this story.
但随着时间推移，恶作剧对话似乎演变成了更正规的对话。我记得我的朋友们打电话问诸如：“嘿，希瑟，44号竖排是什么？”“希瑟，你觉得呢？我该参加长曲棍球队吗？”“希瑟，你觉得绿色怎么样？”但我直到克里斯汀告诉我这个故事前，都不知道这些对话有多严肃。
One night I came home late. And things were really screwed up with the family at that point. My sister was in either the hospital or boarding school. And my parents had separated at that point. And I was just feeling awful. And it just occurred to me that I could call Heather.
那天晚上我很晚回家。那时候家里的情况真的很糟糕。我妹妹要么是在医院，要么是在寄宿学校。我父母那时已经分居了。我感觉糟透了。然后我突然想到我可以打给希瑟。
What had you been out doing? Do you remember?
你之前出去做什么了？还记得吗？
Well, I was probably out drinking somewhere. So yeah, you probably dropped me off at home. And I went up to my room. And well, I probably sulked for about 20 minutes. But then I decided to call him.
嗯，我可能是在外面喝酒。所以是的，你可能把我送回家了。我上了楼。然后，我可能生了20分钟闷气。但随后我决定打给他。
I think I just needed someone to talk to. I really was just trying to think. Should I call my grandmother? Should I call that girl I was friends with that summer four years ago or something? Like who can I talk to? And we had probably-- maybe we had prank called him that evening. And so I decided to call him back. And I am not quite sure what my motives were for doing it. It was just I knew that he would pick up the phone, even though it was probably 1 o'clock, 2 o'clock in the morning. And I knew that he would listen to me. And he wouldn't change the subject.
我想我只是需要有人谈谈。我真的只是在想。我该给我祖母打电话吗？我该给四年前那个夏天认识的朋友打电话吗？谁能跟我聊聊？我们那天晚上可能确实恶作剧打过他。所以我决定回拨过去。我不确定我这么做的动机是什么。我只是知道他会接电话，即使当时可能是凌晨1点或2点。而且我知道他会听我诉说。他不会转移话题。
Kirsten's life was pretty bad around this time. Besides her parents' divorce, one of her sisters had a fatal brain disease, had lived in a hospital almost all her life and was never able to walk or talk or be part of the family. And her other sister had recently tried to kill herself.
克里斯汀那段时间的生活非常糟糕。除了父母离婚，她的一个姐妹患有致命的大脑疾病，几乎一生都住在医院里，从没能走路、说话或成为家庭的一部分。她的另一个姐妹最近试图自杀。
I just started telling him about it, and that I felt really helpless and hopeless when it came to my sister who was in the hospital. And that she didn't realize how much we loved her. And she didn't value her own life. And that was something that Heather and I discussed, feelings of guilt and feelings of anger towards people that you're supposed to love. Just to repeat to somebody over and over again, I'm guilty. I feel guilty. I feel awful.
我开始对他倾诉，说当涉及到我那个在医院的姐妹时，我感到非常无助和绝望。说她没意识到我们有多爱她。她不珍惜自己的生命。那是希瑟和我讨论过的事情，关于内疚感，以及对那些你应该去爱的人的愤怒感。就是一遍又一遍地对某人重复：我很内疚。我感到内疚。我感觉糟透了。
Because Heather-- because I couldn't see his face, because I didn't have to run into him at the grocery store or on the street, I think that made it a lot easier to tell the truth, be honest with myself and honest with my feelings, just because he was some guy on the other line who was just listening to me. And he didn't say, well, this is what I would do or this is what you should do. It was just brief statements, just like, oh, that must have been terrible, or it sounds like your mother has really tried hard to get your sister well, or something.
因为希瑟——因为我看不见他的脸，因为我不需要在杂货店或街上碰到他，我认为这让我更容易说真话，对我自己诚实，对我的感受诚实，只是因为他是个电话那头的陌生人，他只是在听我诉说。他没有说，噢，这就是我会做的，或者你应该做什么。只是简短的话语，就像，“噢，那一定很可怕，”或者“听起来你母亲真的非常努力想让你姐妹康复，”之类的话。
Then when I told him that my oldest sister had never been able to talk to me, he was like, oh, that must be devastating. Tiny little statements that were just sympathetic.
然后当我告诉他我的大姐妹从没能和我说话时，他说，“噢，那一定很让人心碎。”都是一些同情的微小陈述。
I couldn't believe Kirsten could actually confess like this to Heather. Prank call Heather? That weird old guy we make fun of at parties?
我简直不敢相信克里斯汀竟然能这样向希瑟坦白。恶作剧电话的那个希瑟？那个我们在聚会上嘲笑的奇怪老头？
I hope he knows that what he did for me, that I really appreciate him listening to me. And I just hope that he knows that he's not a scumbag and that he's helped me. It would be nice to tell him thank you again. I almost don't want to hear what he has to say about it, because it was something that was really personal for me. And I couldn't bear it if he won't think it's as special as I do. I wonder if he really cares, or if he just wanted to listen just to hear about different people.
我希望他知道他为我所做的一切，我真的很感激他的倾听。我只希望他知道他不是个渣滓，他帮助了我。如果能再跟他说声谢谢就好了。我几乎不想听到他对此会说什么，因为它对我来说是非常私人的事情。如果他觉得这事不如我感受到的那样特别，我会受不了的。我想知道他是在乎，还是他只是想听听不同人的故事。
Whatever happened to Heather? Was he still alive? Did he still have the same number? I picked up the phone and dialed H-E-A-T-H-E-R. Sure enough, he answered. And he agreed to talk to me for this story, so long as I didn't give out his real name. We arranged for me to call him the next day from the radio studio.
希瑟后来怎么样了？他还活着吗？他还在用那个号码吗？我拿起电话拨了H-E-A-T-H-E-R。果然，他接了。他同意接受我的采访，只要我不透露他的真实姓名。我们安排第二天从电台演播室给他打电话。
Hello.
你好。
Hi, Heather. It's Jessica. How are you?
嘿，希瑟。我是杰西卡。你好吗？
I'm pretty good. How are you doing today?
我还不错。你今天好吗？
I'm very good. Do you remember our conversation last night?
我很好。你记得我们昨晚的谈话吗？
Yeah, a little bit of it.
记得，记得一点。
OK. Well, I'm calling you back from the radio now. And I wanted to go ahead and ask you some questions. Is that all right?
好的。我现在是从电台给你打电话。我想继续问你一些问题。可以吗？
I'll try.
我会试试。
OK, great. There's something I'm dying to know about, which is how did this start?
好的，太棒了。有一件事我非常想知道，那就是这一切是怎么开始的？
It started way back in 1951, when some kids were having a sleepover. And one of them happened to have the name Heather. And she said, well, call my name and see if anybody answers the phone. So when they did I answered the phone, and carried on a nice conversation with them. And it has been going on ever since.
这始于1951年，当时几个孩子在举行过夜派对。其中一个刚好叫希瑟。她说，“嘿，打我的名字，看看有没有人接电话。”当他们打过来时，我接了电话，并和他们进行了愉快的交谈。从那以后，这事就一直持续着。
You've been talking to people on the phone for over 50 years?
你已经和电话里的人聊了50多年了？
Yeah, I guess so. I never did figure it that way. But time flies by too fast.
是的，我想是这样。我从没那样算过。但时光飞逝太快了。
During our conversation, I found out a lot of things about Heather that I had never thought to ask as a kid. He became less mysterious and more like a normal old guy. He fought in World War II and the Korean War. When he got out, he got a job with the government on a military base. He's retired now. He still likes to hunt and fish.
在我们的谈话中，我了解到了很多我小时候从未想过要问希瑟的事情。他变得不再那么神秘，更像一个普通的老头子。他参加过二战和朝鲜战争。退伍后，他在一个军事基地的政府部门找到了工作。他现在退休了。他仍然喜欢打猎和钓鱼。
He says the number of calls he gets fluctuates. But during peak times it's like 100 a day. He says he never asks for anyone's last name or phone number. He doesn't accept collect calls, doesn't call people back. He does have caller ID. He does not have call waiting. Over the years, he says he has talked to thousands and thousands of people. Most just call him Heather.
他说他接到的电话数量波动很大。但在高峰期，一天大约有100个。他说他从不问任何人的姓氏或电话号码。他不接受对方付费电话，也不给别人回电。他确实有来电显示。他没有呼叫等待功能。这些年来，他说他已经和成千上万的人交谈过。大多数人都只叫他希瑟。
What most people do when they call, they say, is Heather home? And sometimes they hang up, because they expect a woman's voice.
他说大多数人打电话时会问，“希瑟在家吗？”有时他们会挂断，因为他们期待听到女人的声音。
You know, I was just thinking that it's improbable, in a way, that these many people called you. I mean, Heather, you said thousands and thousands. That's incredible. But I think, to me, it's even more crazy that you talk to them, that you decided that you should respond to all these calls.
你知道，我刚才在想，从某种意义上说，这么多人给你打电话是不可思议的。我是说，希瑟，你说成千上万。这太令人难以置信了。但我觉得，对我来说，更疯狂的是你接听了他们，你决定你应该回应所有这些电话。
Well, since my wife died I've just been by myself here. And it helps pass the time. And a lot of them are nice to talk to. Like I say, a lot of them are latch key kids. They come home, and nobody's home. Both the father and mother are working. And they don't have anybody to talk to. So they call up and talk to me.
嗯，自从我妻子去世后，我就一直一个人住在这里。这有助于打发时间。而且他们中很多人交谈起来很愉快。就像我说的，他们中很多是“钥匙儿童”。他们回到家，家里没人。父母都在工作。他们没人可说话。所以他们就打过来和我聊天。
With the people who call you who are older, do they usually want to talk about something different than the teenagers?
对于那些年龄较大的打电话者，他们通常想谈的话题和青少年有什么不同吗？
I don't get too many of what you call older people. I don't get anybody my age. And I don't know how old I sound on the phone. I don't think I sound anywhere near as what my age actually is.
我接到的“老年人”电话不多。我没接到过任何像我这个年纪的人。我不知道我在电话里听起来多大岁数。我觉得我听起来根本不像我的实际年龄。
Can I ask what your age is?
可以问你的年龄吗？
It's three quarters of a century plus one.
四分之三个世纪再加一岁。
That's amazing.
那太惊人了。
You'd be surprised how many people don't even know what a century is or what three quarters of it is if they did know it. You know what I mean? So you wonder how much schooling some of these people got.
你会惊讶于有多少人甚至不知道什么是世纪，或者如果他们知道，四分之三个世纪是多少。你懂我的意思吗？所以你会怀疑这些人到底受了多少教育。
Heather, we were talking yesterday about how you said you thought maybe there were like a dozen people who had called you contemplating suicide. And you said you were able to talk them down, talk them out of it.
希瑟，我们昨天谈到你说你觉得可能有一打人曾打电话给你考虑自杀。你说你能够开导他们，劝阻他们不要那么做。
Well, they were just full of tears, and sobbing, and stuff like that. And they just blurted it right out when I answered the phone. They just said, I'm going to kill myself. I tried my best to calm them down and just say, hey, the good Lord put you on this Earth for some reason. Don't kill yourself, because you might be planned down the road for something great. That's about it, I guess.
嗯，他们只是泪流满面，啜泣什么的。我接起电话时，他们就直接脱口而出。他们只是说：“我要自杀。”我尽我所能让他们冷静下来，只是说，“嘿，上帝把你放在这个地球上是有原因的。别自杀，因为你未来可能还要完成什么伟大的事情。”大概就是这样。
Some of them called me back three or four days later, and said, boy, I'm sure glad I talked to you. And things are good. So that makes the day. The ones that never called back, I never know if they really did it or didn't do it.
他们中有些人三四天后又给我打电话，说：“嘿，真庆幸我跟你聊了聊。现在一切都很好。”所以这就让这一天过得很值。那些从没回拨过的，我永远不知道他们是真的自杀了还是没自杀。
Heather, do you have kids?
希瑟，你有孩子吗？
No, we weren't that fortunate.
没有，我们没那么幸运。
Do you know what percentage of the people who call you are girls and boys?
你知道给你打电话的人中男孩和女孩的比例是多少吗？
No. I would say it's close to about the same. If they're at a big party or something like that, there are boys and girls together. And they seem like they all want to talk and say hello. You know what some kids do nowadays? And I know they're real young. They'll call up and say, oh, I feel terrible today. Would you do me a favor? Would you sing me a song?
不知道。我会说差不多一样多。如果他们在大型聚会之类的场合，男孩和女孩会在一起。他们似乎都想聊天打招呼。你知道现在的孩子怎么做吗？我知道他们很小。他们会打过来说，“噢，我今天感觉糟透了。你能帮我个忙吗？你能给我唱首歌吗？”
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, so I sing a song to them.
是的，所以我给他们唱歌。
Could you sing a song for us now?
你现在能给我们唱首歌吗？
Well, let's see. [SINGING] Let me call you sweetheart. I'm in love with you. Let me hear you whisper that you love me too. Let that love light glowing in your eyes so true, please let me call you sweetheart. I am in love with you.
好吧，让我想想。[唱歌] 让我叫你甜心，我爱着你。让我听你低语你也爱我。让那爱之光在你眼中如此真实地闪耀，请让我叫你甜心。我爱着你。
Oh, Heather. Thank you.
噢，希瑟。谢谢你。
You know, I never thought I could really sing. So I'm glad I'm able to sing some anyway.
你知道，我从没想过我真的会唱歌。所以我很高兴我至少还能唱一点。
Heather, I want to ask a question. What do your friends think about-- do they know about this? Do they know about people calling you? Do you talk about it?
希瑟，我想问个问题。你的朋友们怎么看——他们知道这件事吗？他们知道人们给你打电话吗？你跟他们提起过吗？
No, I don't advertise it. I figure if people want to call me, fine. But I don't advertise it. I don't tell them nothing.
不，我不宣传它。我觉得如果人们想打给我，没问题。但我不宣传。我什么都不告诉他们。
So your friends don't know. Have they ever been over and wondered why the phone was ringing so much?
所以你的朋友不知道。他们有没有来过你家，好奇为什么电话响得那么频繁？
Yes. But I just tell them, that's nobody special.
是的。但我只是告诉他们，那不是什么重要的人。
So it's a secret.
所以这是个秘密。
Well, it's my secret.
嗯，这是我的秘密。
Why is that?
为什么？
Well, I guess maybe pride. Some people are smart, They just want to laugh at you or something like that. They might say why bother or something like that. I don't know. I'm not going to tell them, so I'm not going to worry about that. It's none of their business.
嗯，我想可能是自尊心吧。有些人很聪明，他们只是想嘲笑你之类的。他们可能会说“为什么要自找麻烦”之类的。我不知道。我不会告诉他们，所以我不想为此担心。这不关他们的事。
What do you look like?
你长什么样？
I'm about five seven. I weigh around 170. I have got snow white wavy hair. I've still got it all. And I still got all my teeth, but I've got a few crowns. I used to play a lot of sports, so I still look kind of muscular. I don't have anything hanging over my belt.
我身高大概5英尺7英寸（约170厘米）。体重在170磅（约77公斤）左右。我有一头雪白的卷发。我还全都有着头发。我的牙齿也都在，不过补了几颗冠。我以前经常参加运动，所以我看起来还是有点壮。我的皮带上没赘肉。
How many people ask you that question, I wonder.
我想知道有多少人问过你那个问题。
What I look like? Just some girls.
问我长什么样？只是有些女孩。
Just the girls, huh?
只有女孩，是吧？
Yeah. Sometimes I ask them what they look like and stuff like that. And I say, gosh, you remind me of my wife. Same dimensions, same figure, same hair, and brown eyes. It's just conversation.
是的。有时我也会问她们长什么样之类的。我说，“天哪，你让我想起我妻子。同样的体型，同样的身材，同样的头发，还有棕色的眼睛。”这只是交谈而已。
It is?
是这样吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It was comments like this that made me wonder if there was some other thing going on with Heather. On the one hand, they could be perfectly innocent. On the other, they made my heart sink a little. I mean after all, an older man who spends a lot of his free time talking to kids he's never met on the phone and keeps it all a secret? Kirsten always wondered too.
正是这些评论让我怀疑希瑟身上是否有其他事情发生。一方面，它们可能是完全无辜的。另一方面，它们让我的心稍微沉了一下。我是说，毕竟，一个老年人把很多闲暇时间花在和从未谋面的孩子通电话上，并且一直保密？克里斯汀也一直这么想。
You know, the guys that would call him and make lewd comments or whatever, he would still stay on the line for that. And that makes me think, is that one of his interests too? Like that weird sexual underworld, is he a part of that and just being my therapist on the side? How does it work? Are most of his calls like dirty talk. Or is it all people like me who are just like, I've got to talk to somebody?
你知道，那些会给他打电话并发表淫秽评论的人，他仍然会守在电话旁。这让我觉得，这是不是他的兴趣之一？就像那个奇怪的色情黑社会，他是其中的一部分，只是顺便当了我的治疗师？它是怎么运作的？他的大部分电话都是脏话吗？还是像我这样的人，只是觉得，“我必须跟某人谈谈”？
So do you feel like creepiness comes with the territory with Heather, or creepiness begets the territory? In other words, the creepiness is just there and you have to deal with it, or the creepiness is sort of part of what attracted us to it. And it was a necessary part of Heather.
所以你觉得希瑟身上的诡异感是随之而来的，还是说诡异感创造了这个空间？换句话说，诡异感就在那里，你必须去应对，还是诡异感正是吸引我们去打它的部分，而且那是希瑟必要的一部分。
Well, yeah. It's not like we were calling teen hot lines or anything. We wanted to talk to the guy who nobody was sure about, that the government hadn't inspected and given a patent to.
嗯，是的。这不像我们在打青少年热线之类的。我们想和一个没人确定底细的人谈话，一个政府没检查过、没给过专利的人。
I called Heather back to ask him, basically, if he was a perv. And it just sucked. I creeped him out. I creeped myself out. We both felt bad. And we got off the phone. And in the end, I still don't know the truth is. I believe my original feeling about him. He offered us something that's not generally available to teenagers. Either we had authority figures talking down to us or our peers judging us. There were no boundaries with Heather, and that was the scary but liberating thing about him. There's a reason he became the person everyone first called to screw with and then called back for catharsis. I mean, he could be anyone.
我打回给希瑟，基本上是为了问他是不是个变态。结果很糟糕。我让他感到毛骨悚然，我自己也感到毛骨悚然。我们俩都感觉很糟。我们挂断了电话。最终，我仍然不知道真相是什么。我相信我对他最初的感觉。他为我们提供了一种青少年通常无法获得的东西。要么是我们有权威人物对我们指手画脚，要么就是同龄人在评判我们。希瑟没有任何界限，这就是他身上令人害怕但又令人解放的地方。他之所以成为每个人首先想拿来恶搞，然后又打回去寻求宣泄的人，是有原因的。我是说，他可以是任何人。
Oh, I also wanted to ask you, Heather, if you could describe the room that you're standing in.
噢，我也想问你，希瑟，你能描述一下你现在站着的那个房间吗？
It almost looks like a room in a cabin up north. I'm kind of laying down. And right in front of me is the coffee table. And the TV is on the other side of the room.
它看起来有点像北边小屋里的房间。我正躺着。就在我面前的是咖啡桌。电视机在房间的另一边。
What were you watching when we called?
我们打给你的时候你在看什么？
I'm watching Friends right now.
我现在正在看《老友记》。
Do you like that show?
你喜欢那个节目吗？
It's kind of good. I don't like Ross. He is the one that is supposed to have the most education. But he's the dumbest one of the group, in my opinion.
还挺不错的。我不喜欢罗斯。他应该是那群人里受教育程度最高的。但在我看来，他是那一群人里最笨的。
You're sitting on the train. And you see an old man sitting across from you. Or you're in the doctor's office, or at the car wash, or wherever you are. Heather could be anywhere. He could have one of those strange phones where you can get the area code hooked up to whatever-- on a cell phone. And he's travelling the Earth trying to solve people's problems. Heather. Yeah, he could be anywhere. It's nice to know that he's still out there.
你坐在火车上。你看到一个老人坐在你对面。或者你在医生办公室，在洗车场，或无论你在哪里。希瑟可能在任何地方。他可能有一部那种奇怪的手机，可以把区号连接到任何地方——在手机上。他正在环游地球，试图解决人们的问题。希瑟。是的，他可能在任何地方。知道他还活跃在那儿真是太好了。
That story by Jessica Riddle. Coming up, it take a nation of mommies to hold us back. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
那是杰西卡·里德尔的故事。稍后，国家需要妈咪们来阻止我们。一分钟后回到芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Time to Save the World, stories of people saving the world one person at a time, of people being hit with sudden moments of truth, thanks to complete strangers. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, Fools Rush in Where Mommies Fear to Tread.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目里，我们当然会选择某个主题，并带给您关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，“拯救世界的时间”，关于人们一个接一个地拯救世界，关于人们突然被陌生人点醒的瞬间。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“傻子闯入妈咪避让之地”。
The person who tells this next story of human kindness asked that we not use his name on the radio. He is just not sure what to think about the story still. I can say that he is an art history professor. He was once in the Marine Corps. But that was long, long ago.
讲述下一个关于人类善良故事的人要求我们不要在广播里使用他的名字。他仍然不确定该怎么看待这个故事。我可以透露他是位艺术史教授。他曾经在海军陆战队服役。但那是很久很久以前的事了。
My mother and I were in sort of rush hour traffic. We were going downtown for lunch.
我和我母亲当时在高峰时段的交通流里。我们要去市中心吃午饭。
And she's driving or you're driving?
她是司机还是你是司机？
She's driving actually. And we're having a great time, joking, talking about old movies, as we do, or about the family or something. Just really sweet, really fun. And it was downtown traffic. And it was also a construction scene. So the cars were just creeping along.
实际上是她在开车。我们玩得很开心，开玩笑，聊着老电影，像往常一样，或者聊聊家庭之类的事情。真的很甜蜜，很有趣。那是市中心的交通。而且也是个施工现场。所以汽车一直在缓缓蠕动。
And all of a sudden, a guy in a pickup truck came around us. I suspect now that my mother may not have let him merge or something. But it was all in slow motion. It was one, two, three miles an hour.
突然，一辆皮卡车绕过了我们。我现在怀疑当时我母亲可能没让他并线之类的。但这就像慢动作一样。时速只有1、2、3英里。
So in frustration then, he drove around us, and paused, and bellowed out of the driver's side window at my mother, and called her a really, really, ugly name. In fact, it was a word that I was hoping my mother didn't even know. The C word.
于是他因为沮丧，绕过我们，停下来，从驾驶侧车窗对着我母亲咆哮，骂了一个非常、非常难听的名字。事实上，那是一个我希望我母亲连听都没听过的词。那个C开头的词。
The one syllable C word or three syllable C word?
单音节的C词还是三音节的C词？
No, one syllable C word. And F-ing C word, in fact. So now we're going to pretend, did we hear this? In conversation, are we going to pause to talk about this? And so the conversation falls silent. I guess we say, well, yeah, Martin Balsam was really good in that movie. OK, now long pause.
不，单音节的C词。事实上，是一个F开头的那个词。所以现在我们要假装没听见吗？在交谈中，我们要暂停来讨论这件事吗？所以谈话变得沉默。我想我们大概说，“嗯，是的，马丁·鲍尔萨姆在那部电影里真的很棒。”好的，长久的沉默。
But I can feel my blood boiling at that point. I think I'm going to confront this guy, a guy screaming a few feet away from my mother's face. I can't let this go unchallenged. And so I start to get out of the car.
但在那一刻，我可以感觉到自己的血液在沸腾。我觉得我要跟这个家伙对质，一个离我母亲脸只有几英尺远在尖叫的家伙。我不能就这样放过他。所以我开始下车。
And what are you thinking at this point? Are you somebody who gets in a lot of fights?
这时候你在想什么？你是个经常打架的人吗？
Oh God, no. In fact, I had never been in a fight. I guess I'm hoping for an apology, maybe. So I get out of the car. And I walk up a few car lengths. And this guy is already out of his truck. He's already standing there. And to tell you the truth, that surprised me a little bit. That kind of gave me pause, because he's a big guy. He's easily maybe 75 pounds heavier than me.
哦，天哪，不。事实上，我从没打过架。我想我可能在期待一个道歉。所以我下了车。我走了几辆车的距离。那个家伙已经从皮卡里出来了。他已经站在那里。说实话，那让我稍微吃了一惊。那让我犹豫了一下，因为他是个大个子。他肯定比我重75磅（约34公斤）。
So I was just afraid. I was afraid. So he says, man, you better get back in your car. And I march up to him. And I say, what did you call my mother? You called my mother an F-ing C word?
所以我很害怕。我害怕了。他说，“嘿，你最好回到你的车里去。”我冲他走过去，说，“你叫我母亲什么？你叫我母亲那个F开头的C词？”
And this is the point-- he must not have seen the same movies that I have seen, because at this point, he actually shoves me backwards. So I figure, well, he put his hands on me. And I haul off. And since I'm off balance, I throw this huge left. And oh my God. It's like he didn't even know it was coming or something. I hit him so hard, unbelievably hard.
这就是关键所在——他一定没看过我看过的那些电影，因为在这时候，他竟然把我向后推。所以我想，嗯，他动手了。我挥动拳头。因为我重心不稳，我挥出了这记沉重的左勾拳。噢，天哪。好像他都没意识到拳头要来了一样。我击中了他，重重地击中了他，简直难以置信地用力。
And I'm thinking to myself, please fall down. Please faint. Please let this be over.
我心想，请倒下吧。请晕过去。请让这一切结束吧。
But no, it isn't over, In fact, he staggers towards me. And I see that I've hurt him. But he's coming. Now it's going to turn into a wrestling match, which it does. And so he's got me in this bear hug. And now we're falling across the tops of cars, other cars in traffic. And in fact, we break an aerial off, break a couple aerials off of cars.
但没有，它没结束。事实上，他踉跄着向我走来。我看到我伤到他了。但他还是冲过来了。现在它要变成一场摔跤比赛了，确实也变成了那样。他给了我一个熊抱。我们摔倒在交通流里的汽车顶上。事实上，我们掰断了一辆车的天线，掰断了好几辆车的天线。
And I'm doing everything I can to just keep out from under him, because he's an enormous guy. And it seems like it went on for eternity. Really Hollywood. It was really something. I noticed people are standing now outside of their cars. It is a big show. It's high school now, at this point.
我尽我所能想从他身下出来，因为他是个块头巨大的家伙。感觉好像持续了一个世纪。真的很像好莱坞电影。真的很有看头。我注意到人们现在站在车外。这成了一场大戏。这时候已经像高中生打架了。
And are you thinking, at this point, what am I doing?
那你这时候在想，“我到底在干什么”？
Actually, I had just gotten my PhD the year before. And I'm hoping to God my professors aren't watching or, God forbid, anybody that knows me. And here I am in it. I'm wallowing around in it. In fact, I am trying to keep this guy off of me. And so we're wrestling around on the ground. There are people standing all over the place.
其实，我一年前刚拿到博士学位。我向上帝祈祷我的教授们没在看，或者别让任何认识我的人看见。而我却在这里。我深陷其中。事实上，我正试图把他从我身上弄下去。所以我们在地上扭打成一团。到处都是围观的人。
And I feel a little tug on my shirt, on my shoulder, OK, break it up. It's all over in this little voice. And I think, oh thank Christ. It's the police. And I look, and oh my God, it was this guy's mother breaking up the fight. And she was a little, kind of leathery, sweet-- Granny Clampett, basically, is breaking up this fight.
然后我感觉到衬衫的肩膀被人轻轻拉了一下，没关系，停手吧。在那个小声音里说：全结束了。我想，噢，感谢上帝。是警察。我抬头一看，噢，天哪，是这个家伙的母亲在劝架。她是一个瘦小、有点风霜、甜美的——基本就是“格林普太太”——在劝架。
I remember she was so sweet. You know, honey, it's over. Get up, get up. Come on. It's all over now, she said. And so I get off. And then I kind of shake myself up. I kind of jump back. And God, afterwards my clothing was in tatters, just in tatters, and blood.
我记得她非常甜美。你知道，“亲爱的，结束了。起来，起来。来吧。现在一切都结束了，”她说。于是我松开了手。然后我抖了抖身体。我向后跳开。老天，后来我的衣服成了碎片，满是碎片和血迹。
And his mother helps him back to the truck. And they get in. And I get back in my mother's car. And it was like nothing had happened. The traffic just resumed. And we kind of drove away.
他母亲扶他回了卡车。他们上了车。我也回到了母亲的车上。就像什么都没发生一样。交通恢复了。我们开车离开了。
We drove-- I guess we were going out to lunch at this point. Now we're just driving, in those first few blocks, just away. We're just trying to drive away. And my mother pulls the car over. And I am trembling. And we didn't know what to say to one another. And I said, well, sorry about all that, Ma. And there's a long pause. And she threw her arms around my neck. And she said, nobody has ever done that for me. And I said, really? Dad never did that for you? And she goes, well, honey, we never were in a situation like that. And I said, well, you're welcome. You're welcome.
我们开车——我想我们当时正要去吃午饭。现在我们只是在开车，开过了最初的几个街区，开远了。我们只是试着开车离开。我母亲把车停在路边。我在发抖。我们不知道该对彼此说什么。我说，“嗯，抱歉发生了那些事，妈。”沉默了好久。她用双臂环住我的脖子。她说，“从来没人为我那样做过。”我说，“真的吗？爸从没为你那样做过？”她说，“嗯，亲爱的，我们从没遇到过那种情况。”我说，“好吧，不客气。不客气。”
She actually passed away a few months ago. And I really miss her terribly. In the last few years, every once in a while she'll tell the story or somebody in the family wants to hear the story. And she was really proud. And she wasn't the kind of person that approves of that kind of thing. In fact, one time I heard her tell a girlfriend, she goes, you should have seen my son. He looked like he didn't have a chance, the way he was dressed-- and I guess I dress kind of like a preppy, pretty clean cut-- and boy, he let this guy have it. So she got a big kick out of the whole thing.
她其实几个月前去世了。我真的很想念她。过去几年里，偶尔她会提起这个故事，或者家里有人想听这个故事。她真的很骄傲。她并不是那种赞成打架的人。事实上，有一次我听到她告诉一个女朋友，“你应该看看我儿子。他看起来毫无胜算，穿着打扮——我猜我平时穿得像个常春藤预科生，很干净——但天哪，他狠狠地教训了那家伙。”所以她从整件事里得到了极大的快感。
It's so crazy to think about what experiences you have that will be the memories that stick with somebody as their most precious memories. For your mom, this is one of her most precious memories?
想到哪些经历会成为某人最珍贵的记忆，这真是太疯狂了。对你母亲来说，这是她最珍贵的记忆之一吗？
Isn't that the truth? Isn't that the truth? And for me, I don't know quite how to think about it. I know that my wife doesn't let me tell the story at dinner parties and things. She's embarrassed by it. And I guess I'm embarrassed by it too. In fact, I struggle with whether or not I want my son to know this story. I never know if I should tell this story. I don't know if it's so flattering.
这难道不是事实吗？这难道不是事实吗？对我来说，我不知道该怎么看待它。我知道我妻子不让我在这类晚宴上讲这个故事。她为此感到尴尬。我想我也对此感到尴尬。事实上，我很纠结我是否希望我儿子知道这个故事。我从不知道我是否应该讲这个故事。我不知道它是否那么光彩。
I wonder if you're embarrassed because you're secretly proud.
我好奇你感到尴尬是因为你内心深处其实很骄傲？
Yeah, maybe. Maybe. I guess I do feel that way. I am proud. And hell yeah. Oh yeah. Maybe so.
是的，可能吧。可能吧。我想我确实有那种感觉。我是很骄傲。该死，没错。噢，是的。可能就是这样。
You got him?
你打中他了？
Yeah, I got him now man. My little gift to Mom. Absolutely. [BEEP] That's right.
是的，伙计，我打中他了。我给妈的小礼物。绝对是。 [哔声] 没错。
It was the perfect fight. I felt blessed. Once in your life you have an opportunity like this. How often do you get something-- he was so clearly right wrong, black white, good bad. I mean, because you call somebody's mother a name and then push somebody around, boys, you are asking for it, or so it seemed to me. And I didn't get hurt too badly.
那是完美的一架。我感到很幸运。一生中你只有一次这样的机会。你能多久得到一次这样的机会——他非常明显地是错的，黑白分明，是非善恶。我是说，因为你骂了别人的母亲，然后又欺负人，小伙子们，你们这是自找的，或者在我看来是这样。而且我没受太严重的伤。
[MUSIC - "YA MAMA," PHARCYDE]
[音乐 - "YA MAMA", PHARCYDE]
Act Four, The Science of Good and Evil. And now a test that provides sudden truth from a stranger, based on a science whose goals could not be grander, to aid in the fight between good and evil. Given that, I have to say it is a surprisingly effective test. Invented by a guy named Robert Hartman, who was nominated for the Nobel Prize for his work back in the '70s. Susan Drury reports from Tennessee.
第四幕，“善恶的科学”。现在有一个测试，它基于一种目标极其宏大的科学，能从陌生人那里提供突如其来的真理，以帮助对抗善与恶的斗争。考虑到这一点，我必须说这是一个令人惊讶的有效测试。由一个叫罗伯特·哈特曼的人发明，他在70年代因其研究工作被提名为诺贝尔奖候选人。苏珊·德鲁里从田纳西州报道。
Robert Hartman was born in Germany in 1910. By his early twenties, he was active in opposing Adolf Hitler. This is his son, Jan Hartman.
罗伯特·哈特曼1910年出生于德国。他20多岁时就积极反对阿道夫·希特勒。这是他的儿子，简·哈特曼。
He went as a young man to a demonstration in which Hitler was parading, with his brown shirts and what have you. And he was completely horrified. Actually, he would never go to large demos after that. I mean here were these thousands and thousands and thousands of people cheering Hitler, whom he knew was evil. So he decided somehow to answer the question, if evil can be organized so effectively, why can't good be organized in the same way, with the same efficiency?
他年轻时曾去参加过一场希特勒带着他的棕衫军游行的示威活动。他感到极其震惊。事实上，从那以后他再也没参加过大型示威。我是说，这里有成千上万、成千上万的人在为希特勒欢呼，他知道那是邪恶的。所以他决定以某种方式回答这个问题：如果邪恶能如此有效地组织起来，为什么善良不能用同样的方式、同样的效率组织起来呢？
When Hartman was 23, the Nazis showed up at his door to take him away because he was a leader of an opposition party. He escaped through the back door. And with the help of a fake passport, he fled to America, where he became a philosopher and started working out an answer to the question that would consume him for the next four decades. How do we mobilize the good of the world?
哈特曼23岁时，纳粹出现在他的家门口要抓他，因为他是反对党领袖。他从后门逃脱了。在假护照的帮助下，他逃到了美国，在那里他成为了一名哲学家，并开始致力于回答那个将消耗他未来四十年心血的问题。我们如何动员世界上的善良？
Hartman went about this using methods that scientists today would never use. He tried to mathematically quantify good and evil. If that seems strange, remember that, for Hartman, Freud, and Marx, and Einstein were still new figures on the scene, each one using scientific analysis to understand things science had never really considered before. So Hartman mapped out the kinds of small and large value judgments we make all the time. And he invented a test.
哈特曼使用的方法是现代科学家绝不会使用的。他试图用数学方法量化善与恶。如果这看起来很奇怪，请记住，对于哈特曼来说，弗洛伊德、马克思和爱因斯坦在当时仍然是新面孔，每个人都在用科学分析去理解科学以前从未真正考虑过的事情。所以哈特曼列出了我们一直在做的各种小型和大型价值判断。他发明了一个测试。
From the very first minute that I saw the results, it was like, oh my God. This is scary. This knows things I wouldn't tell anybody.
从我看到结果的第一分钟起，就觉得，噢，天哪。这太可怕了。这知道我不会告诉任何人的事情。
Harvey [? Shauf ?] is someone who administered all sorts of personality tests as part of his job, the Myers-Briggs, the DiSC, all the others. He first took this test 15 years ago.
哈维 [? 肖夫 ?] 是一个因为工作原因管理过各种性格测试的人，包括迈尔斯-布里格斯、DiSC以及其他所有测试。他15年前第一次参加了这个测试。
It was just something that was so unique, and so different, and so far beyond anything I had ever seen before that it was the tool I had always felt was missing, and the one I always felt I would like to find someday.
它太独特、太不同了，而且远超我见过的任何东西，以至于它一直是我感觉缺失的工具，也是我一直觉得想在某天找到的工具。
Perhaps as many as 100 people in the US now administer the test. And they all seem to talk about it this way, like converts.
目前美国可能有100人正在管理这个测试。他们似乎都以这种方式谈论它，像改信者一样。
It was incredible. I have no way to explain it to you, but my jaw just kept dropping, and dropping, and dropping.
这太不可思议了。我无法向你们解释，但我的下巴一直在掉，掉，掉。
It's literally like someone lifted something off of you. You walk out feeling like, OK, thank God I know that now.
这简直就像有人把某种东西从你身上移开了。你走出来时感觉，好的，谢天谢地我现在知道了。
It was more of a spiritual experience for me than anything I had ever experienced before. I mean it's just like the whole world opened up, and there was nothing but light. And at that point, my life changed forever.
对我来说，这比我以前经历过的任何事情都更像是一种精神体验。我的意思是，这就像整个世界都打开了，到处都是光。在那一刻，我的人生永远改变了。
The test is called the Hartman Value Profile, and it is astonishingly simple. There are no actual questions. It's just two lists of 18 objects and phrases that you rank in order from most valuable to least valuable. Some of the items on the first list, a baby, a uniform, a madman, a mathematical genius, love of nature, a rubbish heap, with this ring I thee wed, blow up an airliner in flight.
这个测试叫做“哈特曼价值档案”，它简单得令人惊讶。没有实际的问题。只有两份清单，列着18个物体和短语，你需要按照最有价值到最不价值的顺序进行排名。第一份清单上的一些项目：婴儿、制服、疯子、数学天才、热爱自然、垃圾堆、以此戒指与你结为连理、在飞行中炸毁客机。
Some of the choices seem impossible. Which is worse, burning a heretic at the stake, or torturing a person in a concentration camp, or slavery? The second list of 18 items concerns work and happiness. There are sentences like, I curse the day I was born, and my work contributes nothing to the world. Again, you are supposed to rank them from most to least valuable.
有些选项看起来是不可能的。什么是更糟的，将异教徒烧死在火刑柱上，还是在集中营中折磨一个人，或者是奴隶制？第二份清单的18个项目涉及工作和幸福。有这样的句子：“我诅咒我出生的那天，我的工作对世界毫无贡献。”同样，你要把它们按照从最有价值到最不价值进行排名。
The notion of a test invented to distinguish good from evil seemed so incredible that when I heard it existed I had to take it. And so I called up a company. They send me a test, and tell me to do it quickly. Don't think too much, they say. Just do it. It takes me 10 minutes. And really, it feels like a very strange parlor game, like a horoscope or a test in a magazine, something slightly interesting but immediately forgotten, nothing profound. I send it back, and arrange a time to get my results.
发明一种旨在区分善恶的测试这一观念看起来太不可思议了，当我听说它存在时，我必须参加。所以我打了一家公司的电话。他们发给我一个测试，并告诉我要快点做。他们说，别想太多。直接做。我花了10分钟。而且真的，它感觉就像一个非常奇怪的游乐游戏，像占星术或杂志里的测试，有点意思但很快就会被遗忘，没什么深奥的。我把它寄回，并安排了获取结果的时间。
About a week later, I sit down with a guy named Wayne Carpenter. Wayne studied with Hartman in the '60s. He wears a cowboy hat over his long gray hair. He has a pile of papers with him, reports on me it turns out. But he doesn't look at them. The second he sits down, he just starts talking.
大约一周后，我和一个叫韦恩·卡彭特的人坐在一起。韦恩在60年代曾师从哈特曼。他在长长的灰发上戴着一顶牛仔帽。他身边有一堆文件，原来是关于我的报告。但他没看那些文件。他坐下来的那一刻，直接就开始说话。
In your profile, the first thing that I look at is the fact that you are a very, very keenly perceptive person. In other words, you are aware of everything going on around you. You have an outstanding capacity to understand people. 90% of the time, you size up what a crucial issue is. You may not express it, but you're right.
“在你的档案里，我首先看到的是，你是一个非常、非常敏锐的人。换句话说，你意识到周围发生的一切。你拥有理解他人的卓越能力。90%的情况下，你能把握住关键问题。你可能不会表达出来，但你是对的。”
There is just nothing like having a stranger tell you that it's a scientific fact that you are right 90% of the time. Wayne tells me lots of other good things about myself. Even the negative things he spins to me in a really nice way. For instance, apparently the test scientifically proves I'm a bossy know it all. But Wayne expresses that like this.
没什么比一个陌生人告诉你“你是对的”这件事在科学上是事实更棒的了。韦恩告诉我许多关于我自己的好话。甚至连负面评价他也以一种非常友好的方式向我展示。例如，显然这个测试科学地证明我是一个爱发号施令的“万事通”。但韦恩是这样表达的。
When you see things that need to be done better, you like to give advice and tell people how to do it better. And you don't think about it as something that you are doing in order to create stress for them. But it can create stress.
“当你看到事情需要做得更好时，你喜欢提供建议并告诉人们如何做得更好。你并没有把它看作是你为了给他们制造压力而做的事情。但它确实会造成压力。”
I already know most of these things about myself. But it was different coming from Wayne. The good things felt so official, like I could do anything, really. And the bad things seemed like such discreet little clumps of bad things in easy to understand categories. They're not soaking through your whole personality. It was all fine, except for one thing Wayne said to me about my need to tell people what to do.
我已经知道大多数关于自己的事情了。但从韦恩嘴里说出来感觉就不一样。好的方面感觉很官方，好像我真的能做成任何事。而坏的方面看起来像是分散的小堆坏事，且分类容易理解。它们没有渗透到你的整个人格中。一切都很好，除了韦恩对我关于“告诉别人该怎么做”的需求说的一件事。
As your child grows, that's something to watch out for, because one of these days she'll bring homework to you. And it will be a B plus. And you will look at it and see immediately how to make it into an A. And your natural instinct to help her is to say, you know, if you had made that one difference. And you're going to do that. When she brings you that paper, and it's a B plus, the first response you're going to have-- you're going to do that, Susan. I'm telling you right now. You can't escape that, because that is you.
“随着你的孩子成长，这是要注意的事情，因为有一天她会带作业给你看。那是个B+。你会一眼看到如何把它改成A。而你想要帮助她的自然本能就是说，‘你知道吗，如果你做了那一点改变……’你一定会那么做的。当她把那张纸拿给你看，是个B+时，你会有这种反应……你会那么做的，苏珊。我正告诉你这一点。你逃不掉，因为那就是你。”
This haunted me. I didn't care about other stuff. But what he's describing is the opposite of my idea of a good parent. And I want to manage my way out of it. And he's telling me that's impossible too. I can't fix it. That's who I am.
这件事困扰着我。我不关心别的东西。但他描述的与我心目中好家长的观念截然相反。我想要管理我的方式逃避它。而他告诉我这也是不可能的。我无法修正它。我就是这样的人。
I'm supposed to greet you all here at 1:15.
我应该在1点15分在这里欢迎大家。
Every fall, Hartman's followers hold a conference at the University of Tennessee to figure out how to spread his ideas more effectively throughout the world. When I hear the word conference, I imagine throngs of people gathered together poring over the latest scientific exhibits and hurrying to make it to the next panel discussion. But in reality, the conference is just one little classroom. There's a box of doughnuts on a folding table. And half the scheduled lectures, it turns out, have canceled.
每年秋天，哈特曼的追随者都会在田纳西大学举行会议，讨论如何更有效地在全世界传播他的思想。当我听到“会议”这个词时，我想象的是成群的人聚集在一起阅读最新的科学展品，匆忙赶往下一场小组讨论。但实际上，会议只是一个小的教室。折叠桌上有一盒甜甜圈。结果，原定的一半讲座都取消了。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[插入人声]
John, what are we supposed to do next here?
约翰，接下来我们该做什么？
On the day I'm there, the big discussion is about how Hartman's followers can convince the University of Tennessee to teach a class on his ideas. This was the last place Hartman taught. He was by all accounts a dynamic and beloved professor. And yet, 30 years after his death he's mostly forgotten even here.
我去的那天，大家讨论的重点是哈特曼的追随者如何说服田纳西大学开设一门关于他的思想的课程。这是哈特曼任教的最后一个地方。据所有人的描述，他是一位充满活力且深受欢迎的教授。然而，在他去世30年后，他甚至在这里也几乎被遗忘了。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[插入人声]
Tennessee today, the world tomorrow.
今日田纳西，明日全世界。
If Hartman's own students and colleagues can't organize themselves enough to convince his own school to teach his work, how likely is it that his ideas will organize the good of the world?
如果哈特曼自己的学生和同事都不能组织起来说服他的学校教授他的作品，他的思想能组织起世界的善良的可能性有多大？
Back in the late '60s and early '70s, Hartman was actively trying to find practical uses for his test. He sent letters to all the US and European airlines. He suggested giving the Hartman Value Profile to airline passengers as a way to sort out potential hijackers before they boarded the planes. He was rejected by them all.
回到60年代末和70年代初，哈特曼正积极为他的测试寻找实际用途。他给所有美国和欧洲的航空公司写了信。他建议将“哈特曼价值档案”提供给航空旅客，作为一种在劫机者登机前剔除他们的方法。他遭到了所有航空公司的拒绝。
In 1970, at the request of President Richard Nixon, Hartman and a colleague, Dr. Arnold Hutschnecker, submitted a proposal to test all American schoolchildren. Hutschnecker was Nixon's psychiatrist, and had been friends with Hartman for years. The proposal was to use Hartman's test to figure out which children had violent and criminal tendencies. Hartman figured about 1 million of them would be identified and placed into 50,000 therapy groups. Hutschnecker preferred the idea of camps. They saw the plan as a way to see trouble before it happened and try to prevent it. Again, here's Hartman's son, Jan.
1970年，应理查德·尼克松总统的要求，哈特曼和同事阿诺德·赫奇内克博士提交了一份测试所有美国学龄儿童的提案。赫奇内克是尼克松的心理医生，与哈特曼是多年的朋友。该提案是使用哈特曼的测试来确定哪些孩子有暴力和犯罪倾向。哈特曼推测大约会有100万人被识别出来，并被送入50,000个治疗小组。赫奇内克更倾向于集中营的想法。他们将这个计划视为一种在麻烦发生前看到它并试图阻止它的方法。再次，这是哈特曼的儿子，简。
And when I heard this I kind of went ballistic. I got him on the phone. My dad lived in Mexico. I said, this is really immoral. And you have to stop Hutschnecker from doing this. You can't segregate potential criminals from society just on the sense of one test. I said, because that's just what the Nazis would have done. If somebody answers the questions in such a way that you say, my God, here's a raving sociopath, but all you have to prove it is a test score, then you have a very moral problem, don't you?
“当我听到这个时，我简直崩溃了。我打电话给他。我爸住在墨西哥。我说，这真的很不道德。你必须阻止赫奇内克这样做。你不能仅仅根据一个测试的感觉就将潜在的罪犯与社会隔离开来。我说，因为那正是纳粹会做的事情。如果某人回答问题的方式让你说，‘我的天，这是个疯狂的社会变态，’但你所有能证明它的证据只有一个测试分数，那么你就有了一个很大的道德问题，不是吗？”
What he didn't understand-- and I give him points for this, because it was a naivete, but it was also great idealism-- is that a tool is also a weapon.
他没意识到的是——我得给他加分，因为这是一种天真，但也是伟大的理想主义——工具也是武器。
The media agreed. "Doctor Pushes Crime Tests for Tots," said the headline in the Washington Post. Time referred to it as an Orwellian proposal. The plan never went through.
媒体表示同意。《华盛顿邮报》的头条写着“医生推动对幼儿进行犯罪测试”。《时代周刊》称其为奥威尔式的提案。该计划从未实施。
Hartman continued to believe that he could use the test to solve these big picture social problems, that the test could serve as a way to good, as a path away from evil. But it just didn't work out that way, because people were disturbed by the idea of doctors going around evaluating everyone. They were scared that some people would end up labeled good and others wouldn't make the cut. And what would happen to them?
哈特曼继续相信他可以使用该测试来解决这些宏大的社会问题，测试可以作为通向善良的途径，远离邪恶的路径。但它没能这样运作，因为人们对医生四处评估每个人的想法感到不安。他们害怕有些人最终会被贴上“善良”的标签，而另一些人则会落选。那他们会发生什么？
These days, there is still one arena where Hartman's test gets a lot of use, the workplace.
如今，哈特曼的测试仍然有一个广泛使用的领域：职场。
We work with them at Procter & Gamble and at GTE for all the sales managers in all the companies they own, Arthur Anderson--
我们在宝洁公司工作，还有GTE的所有子公司、亚瑟·安德森……
Consultants like Wayne Carpenter contract with companies to test their workers and help them solve problems based on the results of the Hartman Value Profile. It is the same test, the same logic. But they never talk about good and evil. They talk about performance, and work styles, and customer service. Wayne's company has tested about a half a million people. Wayne and Bob Terrell, the guy he runs his testing company with, show me and my producer, Starlee Kine, the letter they send out with the test results.
像韦恩·卡彭特这样的顾问与公司签订合同，测试他们的员工，并根据“哈特曼价值档案”的结果帮助他们解决问题。这是相同的测试，相同的逻辑。但他们从不谈论善与恶。他们谈论的是绩效、工作风格和客户服务。韦恩的公司测试了大约50万人。韦恩和鲍勃·特雷尔——他共同经营测试公司的合伙人——向我和我的制作人斯塔莉·凯恩展示了他们发送测试结果时附带的信。
It starts out--
它以……开头
Congratulations. You are now in possession of your value analysis from Axiometrics International.
恭喜。您现在拥有了由Axiometrics International提供的价值分析。
Why congratulations?
为什么是“恭喜”？
That's just the marketing.
那只是市场营销。
If you think about it, the workplace is kind of a weird place for a test like this. Would you want your boss to know exactly the way your mind operates? And yet Wayne helped the Nashville Predators pro hockey team figure out who should be the captain. He helped banks in New York figure out how to bring in new employees from a group of young adults who hadn't made it through high school. He has worked with AT&T, and NASA, and the US Postal Service. So here it is. Here was this very high minded idea, this test born out of the idea of a science of morality, which 40 years later has become a placement tool in human resource departments. And Wayne, though he is devoted to spreading the word about Hartman, is fine with this.
如果你考虑一下，职场是一个进行这类测试的怪异地方。你会希望老板确切知道你思维运作的方式吗？然而韦恩帮助纳什维尔掠夺者职业曲棍球队确定了谁应该担任队长。他帮助纽约的银行从一群没读完高中的年轻人中找出新员工。他与AT&T、NASA和美国邮政署合作过。所以它就在这里。曾经有一个非常高尚的想法，这个诞生于道德科学理念的测试，40年后却变成了人力资源部门的安置工具。韦恩，尽管他致力于传播哈特曼的思想，但对此毫无异议。
I thought, practically, what am I going to do? I can go out and preach, and people can listen. But if they only hear you talk about it, it's not the same.
“实际上，我能做什么？我可以出去传教，人们可以听。但如果他们只是听你说，那是不一样的。”
Is the goal still ultimately that more and more and more goodness is going to add up, and in the long term, big picture way wipe out the bigger evil? Is that still the goal?
目标是否最终依然是更多的善良加起来，并在长期的宏大图景下消灭更大的邪恶？目标依然是这样吗？
Oh, that is the goal. It always has been. That was the goal for Hartman. And that's the goal for me.
噢，那确实是目标。一直都是。那是哈特曼的目标。也是我的目标。
He's trying to reach people one at a time, but even then it's not that easy. Wayne shows Starlee and me the profile of a successful businessman who recently took the test.
他试图一个接一个地影响人，但即便如此也没那么容易。韦恩向斯塔莉和我展示了一位最近参加过测试的成功商人的档案。
The first thing I am going to make aware of is that he's more secure of himself than 90% of the people we profile. The second thing I'm going to do is make him aware that that security and that consciousness, in terms of how he translates that back out, can hurt people without his intending to do it. And he needs to be more conscious of that. He can hurt you and it wouldn't bother him.
“我要让他意识到的第一件事是，他比我们档案里的90%的人更具安全感。我要让他意识到的第二件事是，那种安全感和那种意识，就他如何转化它们而言，可能会在无意中伤害他人。他需要对此有更多的意识。他可能会伤害你，而那对他毫无影响。”
Who did you tell me, on television, this person is?
你在电视上告诉过我，这个人是谁？
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
噢，是的。是的。
Who is it?
他是谁？
Tony Soprano.
托尼·索普拉诺。
But Tony Soprano is a sociopath.
但托尼·索普拉诺是个反社会者。
Well this is a sociopath. This person is a sociopath.
嗯，这就是个反社会者。这个人就是个反社会者。
OK. So what do you do with this if you have a sociopath?
好的。那么如果你面对一个反社会者，你会怎么做？
Knowing this person, I know there's very little I can do other than make them aware of it. And then they have to make the decision.
了解这个人，我知道除了让他意识到这一点，我几乎无能为力。然后他必须做出决定。
But if you make them aware of it, then they have a chance. And without them being aware of it, they don't have that chance. He doesn't see it. So if he sees it on paper, and he starts to think about it, and he says, yes, that's me, and I don't like that--
但如果你让他意识到了，那他就有机会。而如果他没意识到，他就没有那个机会。他看不见它。所以如果他在纸上看到了它，他开始思考它，他说，“没错，那就是我，我不喜欢那样”——
But do you think he's going to change?
但你认为他会改变吗？
The odds are probably against it. I doubt it.
概率可能对他不利。我对此表示怀疑。
Hartman's son Jan says this is the big problem with his dad's ideas and with this test. Namely, once people understand what they are really like, does that make them change?
哈特曼的儿子简说，这是他父亲的思想和这个测试的大问题。也就是，一旦人们理解了他们真正是什么样的人，这会让他们改变吗？
And I can not tell you the number of nights we sat up arguing that point. Our basic argument was that if you can measure things in a way that will reveal to people who and what they are, that the rest will follow.
“我无法告诉你我们有多少个夜晚坐起来争论那个观点。我们的基本论点是，如果你能以一种揭示人们是谁以及是什么样的人的方式测量事物，剩下的就会水到渠成。”
Is it that he thought if people had a system and a way of seeing their own sort of moral limitations or possible failings, they would thus adjust and correct those things?
是说他认为如果人们有了一个系统，能看到他们自己的某种道德局限或可能的失败，他们就会因此调整和纠正那些事情？
That's the logic.
那就是逻辑所在。
Right, that's the logic.
没错，那就是逻辑。
And I would argue that there's nothing more unpredictable in the world than people, and that logic and order don't really exist in human emotions.
而我会说，世界上没有什么比人更不可预测的了，逻辑和秩序在人类情感中并不真正存在。
This is why it's so hard to organize the good in the world one person at a time, because people don't always want to be good, and because when they want it they can't always do it.
这就是为什么一个接一个地组织世界的善良如此困难，因为人们并不总是想要善良，而且当他们想要时，他们并不总是能做到。
Susie Drury lives on a farm in Bon Aqua, Tennessee, where she is carefully monitoring her behavior around her two year old daughter.
苏茜·德鲁里住在田纳西州邦阿夸的一个农场里，她正在小心地观察她在两岁女儿身边的行为。
Well, our program was produced today by Dave Kestenbaum and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Jane Golombisky.
好了，我们今天的节目由戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆和我制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、戴安·库克、温迪·多尔和斯塔莉·凯恩参与。托德·巴赫曼和简·戈隆比斯基提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our show comes from the listeners of WBEZ Chicago. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who sometimes calls me up and asks--
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。我们节目的资金来自WBEZ芝加哥的听众。WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他有时会给我打电话问——
Would to do me a favor? Would you sing me a song?
能帮我个忙吗？你能给我唱首歌吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。